some sad news of the death of the author
Dame Hillary mantel a double Booker
prize-winning author Dame Hillary at
mantel it was announced on Twitter by
fourth estate books they say in their
tweet
we are heartbroken at the death of our
beloved author Dame Hillary mantel and
our thoughts are with her friends and
family especially her husband Gerald
this is a devastating loss and we can
only be grateful she left us with such a
magnificent body of work the image there
of Dame Hillary mantel tweeted out by
fourth estate books and the years of her
life 6th of July 1952 until the 22nd of
September 2022.
Harry mantel published her first novel
in 1988 she's seen as one of Britain's
greatest novelists
and a two-time winner of the booker
prize for fiction for the two novels
Wolf Hall and bringing up the bodies at
the Thomas Cromwell sequence the third
novel in that series uh titled the
mirror and the light was published in
March 2020. so that news announced there
at the death of Dame Hillary mantan